[Applause]
[Applause]
I want to begin by saying a few words
directly to racialized Canadians who
face discrimination every single day in
their lives even in a country like
Canada what I did hurt them hurt people
who shouldn't have to face intolerance
and discrimination because of their
identity this is something that I deeply
deeply regret darkening your face
regardless of the context of the
circumstances is always unacceptable
because of the racist history of
blackface should have understood that
then and I never should have done it
Doubleday direct mo Canady Yankee for
facade ellen terry valve actually Joe
acocella Dolce K sip accepted kadar
pecan no tradition swatch oh it's him
gracias
II know just ketchup Uzi disastrously
Posey Oh blessed perform a massage Allah
kid wot vivre to usual Rebecca Donatella
house across the historical assist the
suggests sanu Jeanette except up the
Fonzie support geological cancer alley
pop a regimental fire German excuse
Poornima
mr. turtle hi David Cochran with CBC
News last night on the plane when we
asked you if the picture that emerged in
the time record was the only time you
had done this you left us with the
impression there was only one other
incident and since then Global News has
released the video which seems to show
that there was at least a third incident
so exactly how many times have you
darkened your skin with makeup in an act
that you have yourself described as
racist I shared the moments that I
recollected but I recognize that it is
something absolutely unacceptable to do
and I appreciate calling it makeup but
it was blackface and that is just not
right
it is something that people who live
with the kind of discrimination that far
too many people do because of the color
of their skin or their history or their
origins or their language or their
religion face on a regular basis and I
didn't see that from the layers of
privilege that I have and for that I am
deeply sorry and I apologize okay
okay that can sit Dean accept that the
pathogen is even not don't my souvenir
me that a needy seeker sorry Jimmy says
Hajime except done the
the the 4c sample Tonya Dickerson que
Viva Tulio
Eric Latinas chemicals are announced a
sipper that person creature sweet
reducible is mamala usually I get
Poornima so to mr. Trudeau how many
times is it just the three that we know
about or other more incidence because
you know people are looking for them and
if a candidate were to come forward now
with this in their history would you
allow them to run for the Liberals in
this election I think that's it that's a
question that we would look at every
step of the way
I think examining the case-by-case
situation examining the actions that
someone has taken
I am certainly conscious that in my
political career as leader and indeed as
Prime Minister we've taken many concrete
actions to fight against racism to fight
against intolerance to fight against
anti black racism specifically to
recognize unconscious bias and systemic
discrimination that exists in Canada and
elsewhere to work to overcome and
recognize intersectionalities that
people live within it in a way that so
many of us simply cannot understand or
appreciate the microaggressions and the
challenges being faced so even though
we've moved forward in significant ways
as a government what I did the choices I
made hurt people hurt people we thought
it was an ally I am an ally but this is
something that obviously I deeply regret
and I never should have done
Larry coach Winnipeg Free Press mr.
Trudeau yesterday you said that you
didn't realize in 2001 that it was wrong
but on brownface but now you do realize
it is wrong and I'm wondering when it
dawned on you that it is wrong I think
it's difficult to become a politician
where you spend as much time as you will
do working hard to represent people
working hard to getting to know a
community like the community I have the
honor of representing picado where there
is extraordinary diversity extraordinary
challenges and yes extraordinary
intolerance even in Sibiu like Montreal
in a country like Canada that people
live with every day and as I've learned
to not just represent people but to
fight for them and to try and build a
better community and a better society
I've learned every day that it is
unacceptable to to engage in this sort
of behavior what okay Cantona Lana that
found have a place on P in community
communicant in Papua Maria and community
multi keeps your hand multi-ethnic Hampi
the person I became
Julius it takes 12 in the army the
junkie for facile at discrimination
attachment to leave your dolly it's a
responsibility a live representative to
delete be found in the travelpod
sailormoon mayor ma uh thingy Jeff
indirect Iran isn't a key no I can point
gg2 jobina considered the privilege key
regional court on a per the reality
version he for fast I said this fellatio
can similar to usual
for such a jerk just report on them up
dizzer Nick the extra secret new devil
does Fatmir autography
me want to get not doctor coming
ministers it was a him iran and in
Papineau in 2008 and later when you ran
for the leadership in 2015 presumably
there was a vetting process I'm
wondering if you thought enough about
this issue that you volunteered that to
in the vetting process or did you ever
declare that this had happened I I never
talked about this quite frankly I was
embarrassed
it was not something that represents the
person I've become the leader I try to
be and it was really embarrassing
I was on the job it badly you big mouth
basket just super funny man Janey
there's a compostable Western culture
sweet the person in Apple II think I
just read in you jockeyed you you're
sick said well me there's no politics
was anything afternoon mr. Trudeau
Theresa right from The Canadian Press
he'd said just a few minutes ago that
you told us last night on the plane that
you are that of all of the different
instances that you recalled have you
since been made aware or remembered of
other instances and if so how many like
it I think it is obvious that this is
something that was deeply regrettable I
am weary of being definitive about this
because the recent pictures that came
out I had not remembered and I think the
question is how can you not remember
that
the fact is I I didn't understand how
hurtful
this is to people who live with
discrimination every single day I have
always acknowledged that I come from a
place of privilege but I now need to
acknowledge that comes with a massive
blind spot I have dedicated my
leadership and my service to Canada to
try and counter intolerance and racism
everywhere I can't but this has been a
personally a moment where I've had to
reflect on the fact that wanting to do
good wanting to do better simply isn't
good enough and you need to take
responsibility for mistakes that hurt
people who thought it was an ally who
hopefully many of them still consider me
in a lie even though this was a terrible
mistake
Jacek
jean-philippe definitive basket
gentleman supa the photo has found
theater succeed i he deeply Sparkle
Jetta
give the Revilla earn 80 Donnie DVDs and
he capitalizes siekerka shows him a
giant waffle demo okay with the promise
of knee
the truth is the Casio hope today's
occasion [ __ ] Oscar for my C - Emma
first ran for one the debajo connector
is an opportunity allowed our cotton
woman she personally política SED I
found with what is on the hope to sickle
to literally Ralph
he instilled a CO measured waffle
connector acre Jetta a burglar one name
that do da K Jacuzzi our Sonoma like a
cosmic knock an Iraqi consumer poor
Linda found in only the first source of
money
I just would like you to answer a very
basic question you've done this all
obviously more than more than two times
why I think when we recognize when we
reflect on mistakes we made in the past
that's a question that we're always
going to be asking why did we do that
why did we think it was okay why didn't
we think it was a good idea at the time
it wasn't a good idea it was a terrible
idea it was something that minimizes and
takes advantage of a reality that I have
not had to live with of being
discriminated against of being
marginalized of being judged for the
color of my skin for my language my
background I come from a place of
privilege and I have endeavored in my
life to put the advantages and the
opportunities I've been given to serve
this country to fight for people's
rights and I have to recognize that I
let a lot of people down with that
choice and I stand here today to reflect
on that and to ask for forgiveness
she wants Casey to throw like a snow
monster citizen I guess you called was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] on forever
pourquoi let's go knife at palazzo pants
acres a day in shows bone to verify
Hayley Pickers suddenly people may join
the company pass mamala the pig -
kochava donor possible repeat skinny
poor Mona don't steal a club a poem
evolution can she pull you a leave avec
lately around kamijo John members RP / e
respect your Cobra Canada - Aviv Sachin
reflects yoga evey demo GU debris he say
- skipper and his opportunity to shiver
Sudan IV the survey in the battle in
Sochi denial me the reality seeker she
blessed a junker shitty saucy
they found a ad a transcript co-funding
on listening to do flip in some fazilet
we can add them yes my teams I finally
believe the Parliament of a person ni
baby they're like you know take a school
and easy this gives all she is
apparently the dishes contain zero jobs
we I can't prepare you never contain
shows courage a MIDI file a Cossack JD
collec the deputy the conceded is a me
diesel a the leader camino tire key matt
wiki for back Cedars
said said about your politic who when I
said about cerimon mayor Key Club a
phony mask on it up and fire her she
blessed director on the junkie a on
walkie Kwame he was evil a trafficker
druggie that man party schwa piss off
see ya designing a slur Ezekiel
even among German excuse puff on demonic
news on coats invader travailler
a Toledo por la cañada mayor a poor
Daniela conscience nickel at the end of
what continuing about the mayor at
little yet they run the load code let me
die sneaky Kiki so stupid they still
come back not about the words c'mon I'm
taking paparazzi arrival sec I have a
point a bird's wings xqz yucky
come madam party on Johnny Cochran from
certain map of even as all the
discrimination can holders of the vive
to leave Oh curses wha the mini DVDs on
the minority disease cursors WA la
communauté LGBTIQ assess what the the
fan circuses wha nepeta tectonically
novel mother discrimination 811
associate a key part about the me
coaxial about the the gesture positive
Hassan's deliver a book The Jonas on the
repertoire in ecology tournament
welcome honker the [ __ ] urges come the
fall see support serve Annalise is a
horrible - it's a prophet Junie reality
and I can beaucoup John the perfect
pasta Sharpie okay there's an for faster
Toledo surpass Castorama
septum on quelque chose K muy FeO kahani
the del sonido football game for
presently severe news on TV
sits in the Netflix yogi initial table
like lump a dragger CTV News mr. Trudeau
there's be confusion about the timeline
of all of this I'm just wondering when
you first told your campaign staff that
there are these images of you out there
that could be embarrassing if they were
to come out in an election campaign did
you know about this in 2015 did you know
about this before then wait when did you
tell those people as as I said I was
embarrassed particularly given the
person that I've become and the leader I
try to be that fights for people's
rights and defends people against
intolerance and racism and I didn't want
to talk about it with anyone because I'm
not that person anymore
I'm someone who understands that deep
hurt caused by actions like that to
people who live with discrimination
every single day when we found out that
Time magazine was looking for a picture
of that event I told my staff
but ultimately the call is mine on when
to talk to people when to act on things
and the buck stops with me and I take
responsibility you had a doctor here he
went to excuse your father was my
minister and an internationalist and I'm
wondering if he knew that you were doing
this in high school
appearing in blackface and what he
thought about it and if he if he didn't
know what do you think he would have
thought oh yeah my father raised me to
try and defend people's rights one of
our family motto has always been provide
counterweights that was the reason he
gave for why he chose to go to Ottawa in
1965 when all the power tended to accrue
towards Quebec City in the quiet
revolution and Quebecers becoming strong
and staying in Quebec he said no we need
to provide counterweights and if you're
strong you need to go where your
strength is most needed that is the way
he raised me and I certainly have tried
to use that privilege that you talk
about the opportunities that I've had in
my life to put them in service of people
who didn't have the kinds of
opportunities that I have that's the
kind of leader and the kind of Prime
Minister I've tried to be the kind of
man I tried to be certainly the kind of
parent I tried to be and in my
conversations with my kids a difficult
conversation I had this morning about
taking responsibility for your actions
and learning from your mistakes this is
certainly something and I think my
father
wouldn't be pleased with how I behaved
but perhaps would feel that taking
responsibility for things is important
when I think of the conversations I have
with my kids this morning I also
recognize that there are far too many
Canadians who this morning had to
explain to their kids what those
pictures were of their Prime Minister
and what kind of society we live in and
what kind of world we need to live in
and how things have evolved but at the
same time I regret deeply parents who
had to have difficult conversations with
their kids that were uncomfortable and
hurtful because of my actions Michels
olio with The Globe and Mail in 2001
students were being expelled for wearing
blackface and and brown face from
schools there was also a spike spike Lee
movie about it in 2001 when did you
realize that blackface was racist
as I've said the privilege of
representing the community of papadum
a extraordinarily multicultural
community where any given crowd looks a
lot like this crowd here in Winnipeg
have people every different background
every different origin and the
responsibility of not just sticking up
for people of all different backgrounds
but but fighting for them and defending
them that is something that made it very
very clear to me that minimizing or
further marginalizing people by dressing
up that way is absolutely unacceptable
that's following international media
including the BBC New York Times and
al-jazeera have published stories about
this are you concerned that your
behavior including you know not talk to
me about this for 18 years publicly has
damaged Canada's reputation and if so
what were you doing out it I think we
all need to recognize it even in an
incredible country like Canada there's
still a lot of more work to do
people are still facing discrimination
of marginalization every single day an
anti black racism unconscious bias
systemic discrimination they still exist
systemic discrimination still exists
in our schools in our universities in
our workplaces in our communities
racialized Canadians everyday faced
extra barriers extra comments
disparaging remarks that they have
learned to live with as the reality of
their day-to-day lives and we must all
in Canada and everywhere around the
world pledge ourselves to make sure we
are fighting to make it better
but there's lots of things we can and
must do that includes recognizing
terrible mistakes of the past that's
what I am doing that's what I have tried
to do as as Prime Minister in many
occasions and that's why we're going to
continue to recognize that still
indigenous peoples in this country face
unacceptable living situations fewer
opportunities these people who were
promised shared partnership and
stewardship of the land and respect were
treated with everything but for
centuries and we are beginning on the
road of reconciliation now but there is
still a long way to go
Canadians of who come from different
parts of the world whether they're first
generation or fifth generation continue
to face
intolerance and marginalization we have
much more to do and I am not afraid of
standing up in front of the world and
saying you know Canada's a pretty great
country Canada's the best country in the
world but we have a lot more work to do
all of us and
that is something that I will continue
to pledge every single day I have to do
it
Brittany hubsan 8010 national news I'm
gonna switch gears a little bit earlier
this week children my child advocates
from across the country came together to
say that the federal government is not
doing enough to address youth suicides
if the Liberals are reelected will you
implement a national suicide strategy
prevention plan and if so when would you
implement that and what would it look
like we made significant moves forward
on this terrible tragedy there are far
too many communities across the country
where children are taking their lives
where suicidal ideation where lack of
opportunities societal and
intergenerational inequities have led to
unacceptable rates of youth suicides and
tremendous tragedies for families for
communities we need to do a better job
of addressing and yes we continue to
move forward on things like national
strategies to prevent youth suicide but
it takes more than just strategies it
takes concrete investments which is why
we've made investments in mental health
service workers in a hotline to help out
for indigenous communities in
investments in education and in new
schools and in new health centers and
investments in indigenous languages and
culture recognizing that someone who is
proud of their identity and their
language and can use their language is
far less likely to fall victim to
suicidal ideation and suicides but
the problem continues we need to do much
much more and we will continue to do
much much more if we get that
opportunity also this week a new report
was released in Manitoba showing that
the rate that First Nations people are
dying at younger rates than
non-indigenous people but we know that
that's happening across the board in
Canada and this continues to happen
since the Liberals have been in power
for the past four years
if reelected what are you going to do to
change that we have made significant
progress over the past four years on
tangible things like lifting boil water
advisories we've lifted 87 long-term
boil water advisories in indigenous
communities but there's still more than
50 to go although we feel we are on
track to lifting all those that remain
by the five-year mark in the spring of
2021 that we had committed to we are
investing in new schools we're investing
in new health centers we are investing
in better partnerships in in support for
First Nations and indigenous
post-secondary education we're working
directly with the maytee Nation on
economic development and investments
were moving forward on an indigent urban
indigenous strategy as well to recognize
all those indigenous peoples who face
real challenges in our urban
environments there is so much more to do
we have taken meaningful steps forward
that have made a significant Snicket
significant difference in the lives of
many indigenous people we're the first
to recognize there is still a long way
to go what took generations and indeed
centuries to break it's going to take
time to fix and I am impatient but I
also know the only way to move forward
properly is in full partnership with
indigenous peoples is empowering
indigenous communities themselves to
determine the right path forward for
them and that sometimes takes a little
bit longer because in many cases these
communities have never been asked what
it is that they
before so we will work with them and be
there to respect them to empower them
and to build the future that they choose
not the future that we think from Ottawa
would be the right future for them that
takes a little longer
I will admit and every day longer we
take means more kids struggling for
longer but we have to get this right and
we have to do it in the full spirit of
respect and partnership and that is what
our government has been focused on and
will continue to be focused on David
aching from Bulbul news good morning
good afternoon sir Master I know
there'll be a lot of people here today
of all races who will be very happy to
hear you denounce racism in all this
form in your earlier behavior but the
prime minister job was not created so
you could work through your issues maybe
it's time that you realize you're not
the indispensable man as the leader of
the Liberal Party as the Prime Minister
you have very many capable leaders in
your party that perhaps you should step
aside for some reflection for some more
understanding and discussion
have you considered asking someone else
to lead the party in this election I
spent the morning speaking with
candidates with fellow liberals with
allies with leaders within racialized
communities across the country and I
will continue to do the work that is
necessary to keep us moving forward in
the right way Canadians have an
important choice to make
Canadians have an important choice to
make on October 21st and I trust
Canadians to make that right choice I
certainly hope that they will continue
to support us in the work that we're
doing but they might not and I know that
that is something that all Canadians get
to decide and they get to bring in all
sorts of different factors because every
Canadian is a different way of looking
at what matters to
and all I hope for is a Canadians take
very seriously this responsibility and
this choice that we will make as a
country on October 21st and until then I
will continue to put forward the very
best team the very best approach that I
can to talk about how we're gonna build
a better future for Canadians I'd like
to just follow up on the tone now of the
campaign it had a different tone until
yesterday and that tone was largely
involved with your party finding lots of
very questionable use for many of your
opponents one of them right here in
Winnipeg in Winnipeg north can you tell
us how the tone is going to change as we
start talking about things is it going
to be so important to be digging up
people's social media posts of the last
two three four years are you gonna be
focused on that or your party pardon me
gonna be focused on that over the past
three days we have put forward
significant policy announcements on how
we will continue to do the work that we
laid out over the past four years work
that resulted in creating over a million
jobs and lifting 900,000 people out of
poverty we talked about raising the
Canada child benefit for kids under 1 to
make sure that more parents have the
ability to give all the opportunities to
their kids we talked about doubling our
investments in child care so that there
is better help for after school and
before school care for parents who need
it and we've talked about supporting our
seniors by increasing the old age
security by 10 percent for seniors once
they reach 75 because we recognize that
costs continue to go up we're going to
continue to make contrasts with our
opponents we're going to continue to put
forward strong pieces of policy that
will demonstrate how we believe that
investing in Canadians is the right path
forward but we will always and continue
to do that in a way that pushes back
against intolerance and tolerance and
racism every step of the way
question mr. Trudeau the next time
you're in a mosque or temple how can you
look at those people and tell them that
you fully understand what they're going
through that is a question I've had to
answer from the very first time I had
the opportunity to walk into a guevara
or a Mandor or a mosque in my writing
and across the country when people see
someone who came from a place of
privilege asking for the opportunity to
represent them in the House of Commons
asking them for the opportunity to be
their voice even though obviously I'm
someone who has had tremendous
opportunities and advantages in my life
and that conversation I had that started
over ten years ago when I started my
journey to being a politician is a
conversation I need to continue to have
every single day whenever I need a voter
whenever I need a Canadian whenever I
meet someone who is looking to me to
serve them to defend them to represent
them and to build a better future with
them and I look forward to continuing
these conversations that I get to have
with Canadians from coast to coast to
coast every single day as I travel
across this country
aha she's a la casona karma reporter
Diego croissant a calculator city a
random one identity on Kijiji repo a la
casita de pon de pinna debut Impala tech
tekele car key value de boku privilege a
de Vaca cetera
come in OTC diverse kappa tdawg le TT
economic Ino Choji demo Trek Josh
Philippa Meza ma voix mi capacity this
opportunity kg o service donkey no
pauses opportunity aqua koko de cárdenas
an uber no mommy
the dis dis da henitaku policia G demo
drinker not a vegetable gave a
presentation to diversity the to Jean me
Rafael a talker the sketch of a
description continued retire and just a
follow-up
you've apologized but what policies and
procedures would you enact that are anti
racism because as you can tell there's
there's people who have been affected by
this indeed we were the first Canadian
government to recognize the deck the UN
decade of people of African descent we
were the first government to
specifically put forward 25 million
dollars over the coming years for the
black community to support grassroots
community organizations to create
opportunities for black youth we put
forward a national anti-racism strategy
that talks about anti black racism the
talks about anti-semitism talks about
Islamophobia we have moved forward in a
significant way in partnership with a
broad range of Canadians of all sorts of
diversities and their groups but we
recognize as you point out there is
always much more to do
we will keep doing it the choices we
make on building a better future for all
Canadians continues to be something that
we are very much focused on as a country
as a government and as a party we will
continue to focus on that
[Applause]